he's in my heart and he is deep in
Apple's DNA his spirit will always be
the foundation of the company I
literally think about him every day his
office is still left as it was on the
fourth floor on the fourth floor his
name is still on the door he stood for
innovation he stood for the simple not
the complex he knew that Apple should
only inner areas where we can control
the the primary technology all of these
things are still deep in our company
there's still things that we very much
believe the the the strive for
perfection for being the best for only
doing the best products for staying
focused he was always looking well
beyond the looking in dealt with
beginners eyes yes he had a gift for
that he clearly had a gift for that and
he took that gift and embedded it in the
company it wasn't a gift that he kept to
himself and so one of whom I wonder that
I'd loved many things about him is it is
a dear friend but he was also a great
mentor he was a great teacher this is
something that's never written about him
but what what he left and not just me
but many of us is what he taught us is
he was one of the best mentors in the in
the world and so it took me a little by
surprise for that I mean he had he had
talked to me about being CEO before and
so I always knew it was his long-term
thing that you would become a CEO got to
become the CEO not not that specific
moment and so he and I had a discussion
back and forth about because I was I was
testing him on this I said you know what
kind of things do you want to do as
chairman versus made it and it's just
sort of having a
good banter winning and I go will select
I said for example ads do you want me to
just do the ones that I think are right
and or do you want to be involved in it
and he said well I hope you'll ask my
opinion on something but he I thought
Charlie on that day that he would be
chairman for a long time that I'd be CEO
for a long time and that we would
continue to work together and so and he
knew when he chose me that I wasn't like
him that I'm not a carbon copy of him I
he and so he obviously thought through
that deeply about who he wanted to lead
Apple and so that I have always felt the
responsibility of and I've wanted
desperately to continue his legacy and
the Apple I deeply love and so I from
the onset I wanted to pour every ounce
that I had in myself into the company
and but in terms of of being everything
he was I've never had that objective
I've never had the objective of being
liked him because I knew the only person
I can be as the person I am right and
I'm not an actor I'd be terribly
Hollywood and and and so that's what
I've done I've tried to be the best Tim
Cook I can be